okay 835 grams weighing less than a bag
of sugar koala joey dara is having a
checkup look in your mouth
she and her injured mother were rescued
from a sydney roadside a month ago
climate change and rapid urbanization
are putting the whole species under
threat
with warnings they could be extinct in
new south wales by 2050
this is unprecedented and we're in
tipping point times more trees are being
cut down more areas are being built up
we're having
huge fires and and all these things
eventually will will have major impact
not just on koalas but all the other
animals that live in the same habitat
that they do
do you know if this pile is injured no i
don't so the first point of what we do
is we assess to make sure the koala is
fit and fine and okay without any
injuries volunteer tracy is responding
to a growing number of koala call outs
the adrenaline kicks into them and they
just want to get away from whatever it
is that's into them
the young koala is worryingly close to a
busy road and houses it's not rapid
breathing
rapid breathing would would tell me it's
heat stress and also that there may be
an injury
it appears unhurt but the team will
patrol to make sure it stays away from
the traffic
this is a perfect example of the
pressure that our lives put on koalas
lives the more we encroach in their
territory the higher the risk it's
estimated every year four thousand are
killed by dogs and on the road
climate change is another threat
wildfires killed thousands of the
state's koalas in 2019.
sydney's last healthy and thriving
colony live in the trees you can see
here
but developers have been given
permission to build thousands of homes
nearby
why build on an area which is so close
to a very active koala population so the
project is really focusing on developing
on areas that have been cleared for some
time
and as a result of that we're able to
then enhance and protect areas of
existing habitat to provide more habitat
and better connections for the
population
the state government and developers say
they're committed to protecting koalas
with inclusions like animal underpasses
fences and conservation zones but
campaigners are scathing if you were
trying to wipe out koalas in new south
wales you do exactly what the new south
wales government is doing you would find
the habitat where they are surviving and
succeeding and you would start to
declare that as
housing in the last three years it's
feared new south wales has lost around
40 percent of its koalas
unhindered
drought disease and development
could mean they disappear completely
siobhan robbins sky news in sydney